une situation pratiquement de guerre
civile nous sommes ici au coeur d'un
système extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt
à la fois intérieure et extérieure de
toute façon
mafieux cela ne peut que contribuer à la
dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
[Musique]
et
l'ex ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
mise en examen pour mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui elle a été entendu ce
vendredi dans le cadre de l' enquête de
la cour de justice de la république sur
la gestion gouvernementale de l'épidémie
de e.coli de 19 une première dans ce
vaste dossier
[Musique]
emmanuel macron salue la formation d'un
nouveau gouvernement au liban c'est une
condition à l'octroi de l'aide
internationale
un nouveau cabinet composé de 24
ministres et leur a fallu plus d'un an
de tractations politiques pour y
parvenir sur fond de colère des libanais
contre la corruption et ses dirigeants
[Musique]
après le froid joe biden soufflent le
chaud sur la chine le président
américain s'est entretenu par téléphone
avec son homologue chinois une première
en sept mois objectif selon la maison
blanche éviter que leur concurrence nous
mêmes à un conflit
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur un rt france une première
dans l'enquêté menée depuis juillet 2020
sur la gestion gouvernementale de la
crise sanitaire agnès buzyn l'ex
ministre de la santé a été mise en
examen pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui une décision de la cour de
justice de la république rendue après
une journée d'audition pour l'ancien
ministre de la santé retour sur les
raisons de ce verdict avec valentin
carpentier
certes il ya des contingences de la vie
politique et les imprévus parfois
indignes d'une campagne
mais c'est aujourd'hui un nouveau
défense
tout commence maintenant une démission
après 2 ans et 8 mois de fonction
ministérielle
le 17 février 2020 agnès buzyn annonce
son départ du ministère des solidarités
de la santé pour se présenter à la
mairie de paris
plus d'un an après l'ancien ministre
n'est pas devenu maire de la capitale et
vient même d'être mise en examen pour
comprendre cette situation il faut
remonter au 23 janvier 2020 tous les
établissements de santé connaissent la
conduite à tenir les samu sont en alerte
les services d'urgence sont en alerte il
ya également des équipes notamment une
équipe de soins dédiés à l'aéroport de
charles de gaulle qui peut prendre en
charge un patient fébrile à l'arrivée
d'un avion donc en réalité en france
nous sommes extrêmement bien préparés
pour ce type évidemment de
d'épidémie début 2020 le coronavirus
n'en est qu'à ses prémices le virus
touche uniquement la ville de wuhan en
chine et la france est encore épargné le
gouvernement français pensent donc être
préparé à toute éventualité
problème la situation évolue très vite
trop vite dames et messieurs j'ai été
informé hier soir du décès du patient de
80 ans qui était hospitalisée à
l'hôpital bichat depuis le 25 janvier
dernier et qui était atteint d'une
infection pulmonaire par le coronavirus
il s'agit là du premier décès par le
corona virus en dehors de l'asie donc le
premier décès en europe en deux semaines
la confiance fait place à l'inquiétude
critiqué pour sa gestion du début de la
crise agnès buzyn est remplacé par
olivier ferrand
en juillet 2020 une enquête sur la
gestion de l'épidémie est ouverte
l'ancien ministre est l'une des
premières à témoigner pour elle une
chose est claire son ministère n'a
jamais rien pris à la légère il n'y a
pas une journée où ne prenons pas des
décisions pas une journée où nous
n'avons pas anticipé
toujours par rapport à l' oms l ecdc
nous sommes toujours en avance par
rapport aux décisions internationales
donc
en aucun cas je peux vous dire qu en
aucun cas je peux laisser dire que le
ministre de la santé a été lent agnès
buzyn donc de nouveau été entendus ce
vendredi une audience au cours de
laquelle l'ancien ministre a été mise en
examen pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui une première inculpation pour
une ministre depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire qui pourrait ne pas être la
dernière des perquisitions ont déjà été
menées le 15 octobre dernier chez
edouard philippe jérôme salomon et
olivier ferrand
on va voir les conséquences de cette
affaire sur la gouvernance française
écoutez à ce propos et mary glisser
glisser secrétaire général adjoint du
cndd tant que le millénaire
ya un clip tout en emportant notamment
avec les perquisitions qui ont eu lieu
au domicile de monsieur verront alors
qu'il n'a encore en est en exercice de
finalement avoir des ministres qui vont
plutôt gérer le risque pénal plutôt
qu'agir est de prendre des mesures en
anticipation pour gérer la crise avec
ses démarches
on peut se demander si finalement les
ministres et les différentes
administrations sont pas dans une
solution davantage d'attentes pour gérer
le risque judiciaire vérifier d'abord
qui ne seront pas mis en examen il n'y
aura pas de poursuites avant
d'éventuellement prendre des décisions
et c'est tout le point clé est la mise
en tension entre l'impératif de rendre
des comptes et en même temps permettre
l'action n'est pas paralysé l'action
publique qui en france est déjà paralysé
avec une bureaucratie de plus en plus
importante et la mobilisation contre le
pass sanitaire toujours en vogue
neuvième samedi les consécutif de
manifestations demain trente mille
personnes sont attendues à à paris un
cortège est à l'initiative à des gilets
jaunes léger les jaunes à un mouvement
qui a coûté à la carrière à certaines
figures emblématiques c'est le cas de
tristan à lauzach le jeune homme de 29
ans a payé le prix fort de son
engagement il a reçu l'une de nos
équipes chez lui en bretagne reportage
signé renaud parquet avec le récit de
médiers ski fis
[Musique]
il n'est ni de droite ni de gauche
plutôt défiant à l'égard de la politique
en général il y a trois ans tristan
démissionne de son poste de conseiller
funéraire pour se consacrer au combat
dès gilet jaune lassé de devoir payer
trop de taxes et après un an sans
activité il se met en quête d'un nouvel
emploi
j'ai postulé j'ai postulé et donc
plusieurs entreprises me refuser exemple
dans une entreprise pas très loin d'ici
au bout d'une semaine il me dit bon bah
monsieur losail votre contrat est
renouvelé très bien très bon travail il
n'y a pas de souci et finalement des
mises plus tard il est revenu me voir en
disant ah mais vous êtes tristan lozach
le gilet jaune et j'ai dit bah oui oui
et là il m'a répondu dehors voilà sauf
que j'avais pas d'enregistrement n'y
avait pas de vidéo il n'y avait pas de
salariés autour donc c'était très
compliqué de le prouver quand c'est
comme ça on se tait qui bat on quitte
l'entreprise joint au bout d'un moment
je pense qu'il faut aussi comprendre
pourquoi les gens s'engagent dans des
mouvements comme ceux comme comme cela
c'est des gens qui n'arrivent plus à
vivre au 15 du mois tristan estime son
combat légitime il ira jusqu'au bout et
ce malgré les menaces de mort qu'il a
reçu
des menaces de mort j'en ai eu de la
part de l'extrême droite et j'en ai eu
de la part de l'extrême gauche donc je
ne fais pas de différence je ne sais pas
qui sont ces personnes parce que à
défaut de me menacer de mort ils sont
pas capables de d'afficher leur nom et
prénom derrière c'est toujours par des
thés combien dé facebook cacher mais ce
père de trois enfants est déterminé le
19 janvier dernier il décroche un emploi
de chef de conduite à la coop des
masques une aubaine de la valeur d'un
smic qui lui permet de faire vivre sa
famille et de payer plusieurs amendes
pour différentes entraves j'ai un peu
plus de 500 euros d'amendé en tout j'ai
eu trois mille euros donc jamais paient
déjà une partie mais il me reste cinq
cents et quelques euros damende en
jours-amende et donc c'est vrai que si
je vais pas y pas ça se transforme donc
en pleine de prison ferme donc voilà
aujourd'hui c'est important de pouvoir
ramener un salaire pour faire en sorte
de là deux payés et que je me retrouve
pas en fermer aujourd'hui parce que
voilà parce que j'avais décidé de le
défendre en cause ce samedi il se rend à
paris pour défiler contre le pass annie
terre mais pas contre la vaccination
précise de gilet jaune tristan a reçu
ces deux doses de vaccin anti qu'ovide
son combat reste intacte avec un rêve au
bout être un jour propriétaire de sa
propre entreprise funéraire
et même à quoi a salué la formation d'un
nouveau gouvernement au liban après
treize mois d'attentes marquée par des
tractations politiques à n'en plus finir
24 ministres composent le nouveau
cabinet ces longs mois de négociations
ont aggravé une grave crise économique
qui a fait sombrer des millions à deux
libanais dans la pauvreté ce nouveau
gouvernement est donc déjà sous pression
face aux nombreux défis à relever
écouter le premier ministre ali banes
les larmes inondent les yeux d'une mère
lorsque son fils aîné quittent le pays
tandis qu'elle est incapable d'acheter
un comprimés de paracétamol ou
d'aspirine elle ne peut pas se les
procurer dans le pays
et c'est quelque chose que nous savons
et ressentons tous
la situation est extrêmement difficile
et nous le savons tous
mais il n'est pas impossible d'être unis
en tant que libanais
et malgré l'annoncé de ce nouveau
gouvernement pas certain que les choses
changent selon fouad zmokhol président
du rassemblement des dirigeants et chefs
d'entreprise libanais dans le monde
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire qu'on a un
optimisme à ses briquets et timide d'un
côté je veux dire on est soulagé qu'on
revienne sur notre constitution et qu'on
a un gouvernement mais quand je dis
optimise timide il ne faut pas oublier
que ceux qui ont formé aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ce qui tire par les
ficelles les ministres qui ont été
nommés ou autre ce sont les mêmes ce
qu'ils ont causés quand même ce cette
chute dramatique c'est les mêmes qui
sont au pouvoir depuis plus de 30 ans
ils sont toujours aujourd'hui et qui
tiennent ce gouvernement ce qu'on craint
que les raisons qui ont empêché la
formation de ce gouvernement depuis 12
depuis 12 mois loose longs mois où nous
sommes tombés dans une
en une dans un drame dramatique jour
après jour donc on craint que ces mêmes
problèmes étaient en dehors de la
plateforme du gouvernement nous suivent
dans la plateforme de ce même
gouvernement on craint aussi que les
pressions régionales et internationales
qui ont donné lieu aujourd'hui à la
création de ce gouvernement parce que
c'est très clair il faut être très
réaliste ce n'est pas des efforts locaux
et des efforts régionaux et
internationaux
on remercie finalement mais en même
temps vous savez que faire face à cette
crise aura lieu aussi à des décisions
très difficiles
le gazoduc north stream 2 qui relier la
russie à l'allemagne est achevé le
kremlin appel ce matin à sa mise en
service ou plus vite un appel lancé ce
matin ouvrage de plus de 1200 km sous la
mer baltique doit doubler est les
livraisons de gaz russe vers l'allemagne
devrait peut-être à opérationnel d'ici
la fin de l'année selon le porte-parole
de la diplomatie russe marya zakharova
c'est la conclusion en tout cas d'un
projet colossal de plus de 10 milliards
de dollars longtemps critiquée par
l'europe les états unis craignant une
trop forte dépendance énergétique des
européens à l'égard de la russie on va
écouter l analyse de pierre emmanuel
thomas docteur en géopolitique
comme les travaux de construction sont
déjà terminées il sera assez difficile
de s'y opposer il n'y a aucune véritable
alternative dans cette situation
en plus les européens ne souhaitent pas
mettre en péril les relations avec la
russie au niveau géopolitique
alors que la proche des etats-unis est
différente bien sûr
vivants dans leur vision pour contrôler
et l'eurasie il faut empêcher une
coopération trop proche entre l'europe
occidentale et la russie
verra donc on perçoit des intérêts
différents mais cette fois l'allemagne
est soutenue par d'autres pays comme la
france qui fait partie du projet
elle soutient ce projet parce que
l'économie européenne a besoin du gaz
russe en matière géographique c'est très
proche c'est efficace et fiable en même
temps à nice et fichiers un historien en
ce qui concerne la russie le gazoduc lui
permet de vendre son propre gaz pour
améliorer à l'avenir ses relations avec
l'europe de lisbonne à vladivostok
lisbonne tout vladivostok in-fusio
violent et l'ambassadeur des etats-unis
à moscou convoqué par les autorités
russes l'objectif présenter des preuves
irréfutables de violations commises par
les géants du numérique américain va
faire le point avec notre correspondant
antoine clair au point
antoinat bonsoir alors les élections
législatives approchent en russie et
moscou qui accuse maintenant les états
unis d'ingérence
oui tout à fait les autorités russes
disent avoir en leur possession des
preuves irréfutables
qui montre des violations de la part des
violations de la loi russe de la part
des géants du numérique américain et ce
dans le cadre des élections législatives
qui arrive ce sera en toute fin de
semaine prochaine afin de faire passer
ce message l'ambassadeur américain en
poste à moscou a donc été convoqué au
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
écoutez j'ai lu trois versions de la
convocation de l'ambassadeur des états
unis au ministère russe des affaires
étrangères
le ministère des affaires étrangères a
convoqué l'ambassadeur et c'est le
ministère des affaires étrangères qui
connaît la véritable raison de cette
convocation il n'y a qu'une raison
l'ingérence dans les élections russes
nous espérons que c'est ainsi que les
diplomates américains ne rapporteront à
washington est pas comme l'ambassade des
états unis l'a expliqué dans un
communiqué de presse déconnectés de la
réalité
en effet dans ce communiqué dont maria
sharapova parle il est écrit que john
sullivan a rencontré le vice ministre
des affaires étrangères le vice ministre
russe des affaires étrangères simplement
pour discuter
de la proche de joe biden concernant les
relations russo américaines quasiment
donc une visite de courtoisie bien et le
bien éloignée de la version russe depuis
le retour des ambassadeurs à la suite de
la rencontre entre vladimir poutine et
joe biden c'était au mois de juin à
genève eh bien le dialogue entre les
diplomates reste tendue on peut le voir
encore une fois même si ce dialogue au
moins le mérite d'exister
merci à vous en train de kerho pour
toutes à ces précisions direct depuis
moscou
100 millions d'américains concerner les
deux tiers de travailleurs du secteur
public et privé aux etats unis la
vaccination obligatoire est étendue à
cette tranche de la population est les
précisions c'est avec grégoire dos et
mph nous avons été patients mais notre
patience a des limites
et votre refus nous coûte à tous
fini le temps de la pédagogie et joe
bail de noces le ton pour en terminer
avec l'épidémie de kovy 19 le président
américain décide de passer à la vitesse
supérieure
mon travail en tant que président et de
protéger tous les américains ce soir
j'annonce donc que le ministère du
travail élabore une mesure d'urgence qui
exige que tous les employeurs qui ont
plus de 100 salariés ce qui concerne
plus de 80 millions de travailleurs
s'assurent que leurs personnels soit
entièrement vaccinez vous présente un
test négatif au moins une fois par
semaine
et
week a ajouté à ses salariés du secteur
privé les fonctionnaires fédéraux de
nombreux employés de maison de retraite
ou encore les écoles ce contrôle fédéral
ce sont au total plus de 100 millions de
personnes concernées par une vaccination
quasi obligatoire soit deux tiers des
travailleurs américains dans
l'opposition républicaine on n'hésite
pas à évoquer le terme de dictature il
ne s'agit pas de liberté did you buy
donne ça ressemble beaucoup à une
dictature
si la vague épidémique en cours semble
avoir amorcé une décrue les indicateurs
sanitaires restent élevés sur les sept
derniers jours ce sont près de cent
cinquante mille nouveaux cas quotidiens
qui ont été enregistrés aux états unis
ils ne s'étaient pas parlé depuis sept
mois joe biden et jean ping se sont
longuement entretenus au téléphone pour
apaiser les tensions entre les
etats-unis et la chine a une
conversation de 90 minutes pour à la
maison blanche ce compact vise à éviter
que la concurrence entre leurs pays ne
mène à un conflit on précise qu'outre la
guerre commerciale entre les deux
nations l'origine du coc u19 et les
accusations américaines envers pékin
pour son manque de transparence alimente
les tensions entre les deux nations ont
faim et on va écouter pierre prg au
politologue et spécialiste de la chine
pour lui cette rencontre est une bonne
nouvelle pour les relations entre les
états unis et la chine
une première grande on compte comme l'y
oblige kelly phonique mais qui met un
peu plus en harmonie les deux grandes
nations au souveraine qui globalement
domine actuellement le monde et c'est
une bonne nouvelle parce que si
l'administration 30 étais je dirais
beaucoup plus intransigeantes avec la
chine comme sur d'autres sujets
aujourd'hui eh bien on a un président
américain je tirais beaucoup plus
intelligente cas matière de diplomatie
internationale parce qu'il va de
l'intérêt de tous y compris du but avait
ni éléments de la chine et de l'ensemble
des pays du monde de rétablir je dirais
à un partenariat ou une concurrence on
peut l'appeler différemment qui fera
peut-être
acharnée où mais en tout cas qui vise à
assurer la paix mondiale
l'administration maiden qui porte
plainte au texas contre une loi anti
avortement la loi texane entrée en
vigueur le 1er septembre interdit les vg
environ six semaines de grossesse ne
prévoit pas d'exception en tête
d'inceste ou de viol une mesure
anticonstitutionnelle selon le ministre
américain de la justice
et puis au mexique une seconde loi qui a
signé l'avortement au meurtre et juger
là aussi anti anti constitutionnelle et
cette fois c'est une décision
hier de justice de la cour suprême elle
intervient deux jours après un jugement
similaire les détails c'est en images
[Musique]
n
au canada j - 10 avant les élections
législatives fédérales un scrutin
anticipé véritable pari politique pour
le premier ministre justin trudeau on
voit cela en images avec grégoire d'où
ces chiens le 20 septembre prochain les
canadiens sont appelés aux urnes pour
élire leurs députés à la chambre des
communes à la tête d'un gouvernement
minoritaire depuis 2000 19 c'est à dire
sans majorité absolue justin trudeau a
choisi de dissoudre le parlement
canadien pour déclencher des élections
anticipées
objectif rehaussé une majorité relative
à l'heure actuelle son parti le parti
libéral disposent de 155 députés soit 15
de moins que nécessaire pour obtenir la
majorité absolue incomprise par de
nombreux canadiens cette dissolution
pourrait en fin de compte se retourner
contre trudeau selon les dernières
enquêtes d'opinion le parti de son
adversaire conservateur erin o'toole
prendrait même la tête dans cette course
électorale si cette tendance venait à se
confirmer justin trudeau pourrait alors
être contrainte d'abandonner son poste
de premier ministre pour se faire une
idée les canadiens ont pu regarder trois
débats électoraux dont un en anglais des
confrontations lors desquels le premier
ministre n'a pas été épargné par les
critiques il a notamment été accusé de
ne pas tenir ses engagements en matière
de politique environnementale
l'onu à interpelle les talibans sur la
façon dont ils répriment les
manifestations pacifiques et qu'elles se
sont soldés par la mort d'au moins
quatre personnes mercredi à les talibans
au pouvoir en afghanistan interdisent
désormais tout rassemblement une
violation du droit international selon
les nations unies on va écouter cette
porte-parole du haut commissariat des
droits de l'homme
mme écran nous demandons aux talibans de
cesser immédiatement de recourir à la
force et de détenir les traitements les
personnes exerçant leur droit de réunion
pacifique et les journalistes qui
couvrent les manifestations
nous rappelons que les manifestations
pacifiques sont protégés par le droit
international relatif aux droits humains
notamment pas l'article 21 du pacte
international relatif aux droits civils
et politiques dont l'afghanistan est
signataire les autorités l'homme
garantir un environnement sûr une
propice et non discriminatoires pour
l'exercice des droits humains notamment
la liberté d'expression et de réunion
pacifique
les restrictions générales
rassemblements pacifiques qui constitue
une violation du droit international
et un deuxième vol d'évaluation
aujourd'hui depuis kaboul l avion a pris
la direction de la capitale qatarie avec
à son bord entre autres 49 français et
leurs familles dont deux familles
rennaise en visite là-bas depuis des
semaines plusieurs associations et des
proches demandait de l'aide le la au
quai d'orsay nos reporters estelle
charger et renault parquet allez vous
rencontrer
il s'en est fallu de peu
cha am a dit ce rennais d'origine
afghane est rentré d'afghanistan le 25
juillet dernier c'est là bas que ce chef
d'entreprise passait ses vacances avec
sa femme et ses enfants lui ainsi que sa
famille ont pu rentrer à temps ce qui
n'est pas le cas de 45 rennais toujours
coincés à kaboul parmi eux une vingtaine
d'enfants chat ahmadi est depuis en
contact avec ces familles ils sont très
très inquiets de la situation
ils sont presque tous tout le monde
était riche réseau il sort pas sauf si
besoin pour aller faire des courses il
ya des familles qui n'habitent pas à
kaboul la les paysans ils sont juste là
parce que il veut pas
raté leur chance donc près de l'aéroport
et ses chats hamadi tente aujourd'hui de
mobiliser l'opinion publique pour
rapatrier ces familles à ses côtés
l'association d'art afghanistan avec à
sa tête ashmat froz ce dernier nous
explique que leurs courriers et les
demandes envoyées au quai d'orsay sont
restées lettre morte on est toujours une
fable affaires étrangères on écrit au
député on la rappelle dans les médias
tout en toutes les démarches qui est
possible on le fait mais pour l'instant
vous nous n'avons pas aucun résultat et
pour l'ensemble des wagons en
afghanistan c'est décevant il se sent
abandonné par la communauté
internationale de l'autre côté la mairie
de rennes nous a fait savoir qu'elle
avait transmis les noms des familles
bloquées au quai d'orsay le ministère
des affaires étrangères quant à lui a
précisé au figaro qu aucune évacuation
ne pouvait se faire tant que l'aéroport
de kaboul ne serait pas rendu au trafic
aérien civil toujours avec l'espoir de
faire bouger les choses la diaspora
afghane rennaise organise une nouvelle
manifestation ce samedi à rennes la
troisième depuis le 28 août
le vice président de l'union européenne
achevé sa visite de deux jours en
tunisie après avoir rencontré des
membres de la société civile et certains
un parti politique son séjour s'est
achevé par un entretien à carthage avec
le président kaïs sayad les détails de
cette visite avec notre correspondant
actualise bassin chebbi
cette visite de deux jours s'est achevée
avec un entretien entre cailly sayed et
josep borrell après l'irak et la libye
le haut représentant de l'union
européenne pour les affaires étrangères
et la politique de sécurité a tenu à
rencontrer les acteurs de la société
civile et de la vie politique tunisienne
josep borrell est venu en tunisie pour
réaffirmer les inquiétudes de l'union
européenne face à la crise politique et
institutionnelle que traverse
actuellement le pays et coûté 7 1 me au
président les appréhensions
européenne
appréhension par rapport à la
préservation de l'acquis démocratique en
tunisie
que c'est le à même de garantir la
stabilité et la prospérité l'idée du
pays
les libre exercice du pouvoir législatif
et la réprise telles activités
parlementaires
font partie et c'est à qui ils doivent
être respectées
dans ce contexte il est important de
conduire le pays vers le rétablissement
de la stabilité institutionnelle en
préservant ses fondamentaux
démocratiques à bruxelles avaient
précédemment exprimé son inquiétude face
au retard du président sayyed à définir
une feuille de route et a nommé un chef
du gouvernement après le limogeage du
chef des chichis le 25 juillet dernier
mais cette visite du représentant de
l'union européenne ne fait pas
l'unanimité ici certaines formations
politiques comme le parti des story un
livre ont fait savoir qu'ils ne
participeraient pas à ces rencontres
invoquant le droit du peuple tunisien a
décidé seule de son sort comme lors du
déplacement de la délégation américaine
en visite à tunis la semaine dernière le
parti destot rien a estimé que la
tunisie doit faire face seule à cette
crise politique sans ingérence étrangère
carthage de son côté n'a fait pour le
moment aucune déclaration même si selon
nos informations un nouveau chef du
gouvernement devrait être bientôt
annoncé et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver dans une trentaine de minutes
reste avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse d'industrie
elle est extrêmement contrôlée pourquoi
puisque reverse 50 5 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires à l'état et à la commune ils
sont donc très intéressé au fait que le
fonctionnement soit line ont fait
exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurances est ce qu il ya
de l'argent suspect nous sommes dans
l'obligation de le déclarer comment se
répartit centre